Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we tackle the question
what would you do if robots took your job?
All of a sudden--
We have a whole--
Due to automation--
Season of television
about this, Link.
Your career needs to change.
Yeah that's right, Buddy--
This is the inciting event
of Buddy System season two.
That's right.
Not to promote that but
we could promote it.
What did you do when you
lost your job to robots?
Well we can talk about
that when we talk about it.
Yeah because there's a lot of parallels
between our Buddy System
season two characters
and the real us even though
it's us in a parallel universe.
By the way, they're releasing
Buddy System season two--
I don't know if we're--
In front of the paywall
at some point so be--
Some point, yeah.
Be looking for that.
We'll make a big deal about
it when it's all there.
Seasons one and two but if
you're gonna only watch one,
watch season two.
That's confusing.
Unintentional plug.
I guess you can watch
season one but anyway,
yeah, there's some robot
stuff happening there.
And just let me say this
whole conversation--
Say?
It spawned from a Reddit session.
You call them sessions?
Yeah I have a Reddit
session as I'm sleeping.
Well .
I sleep.
I don't know how that works.
As I'm going to sleep in my
bed so that's another thing
we may need to tackle is
if that's a good habit
but I went down this Reddit rabbit trail
which meanders through
manufacturing processes,
some eerie anecdotes and
lands smack-dab on you.
Oh I'm featuring in this
Reddit thread directly?
Well I don't wanna say
too much but I will say--
Wow.
You know what, yes.
This Reddit thread that was
featured on the home page
had nothing absolutely in
the world to do with you,
us, anything to do with us at all.
Somehow involved you.
Wow.
I'm suddenly interested.
And that took--
So it was a wild ride on Reddit
and I wanna take you back through it.
I'm planning to participate
in this discussion.
The robots are gonna
take over at some point
in our conversation.
Okay.
But we're gonna land on you inexplicably.
Great.
Well, I'll explain it,
but it's unexpected.
Okay.
Before we get into that, I
do want to tell you something
that happened to me at a party.
First of all, let me just say that--
You're a party animal.
Say it.
I have been
so occupied in the evenings.
Tonight will mark the sixth straight night
that I have had something
that is like kind of
like an involved--
An obligation.
Obligation.
An out of the home thing.
And this one tonight, my wife
is actually gonna go with me
and we're going, I'll just say,
we're going to the Mayans
MC season two premiere.
That's right.
To support our friend Kurt Sutter.
And this is the one that
Jessie's going with me to,
and this morning I was like,
"You ready for tonight?"
And she was like, "What?"
Again?
She was like, "You're
going somewhere again?"
I was like, "You're going with me,"
and it didn't seem to make a difference.
Yeah that's why Christy's not going.
I am going, I'm going with you and Jessie
and I guess Stevie's my date.
Yeah.
'Cause Christy, yeah she's like, "Listen.
"This has been too much stuff happening."
And I mean if it wasn't for a sense of,
well, I wanna go for what
it is but I don't wanna go
because it's just going somewhere else.
I understand that.
And I said, "Listen--"
And I'm almost like,
"You're going, that's good enough
"as if both of us are going.
"That's enough support,"
but that's kinda lame,
I'm not gonna do that.
Well I appreciate that.
I could change my mind.
I could bail.
I wouldn't be surprised
if you did but I certainly hope you go,
but it has been too much and then I say,
"This is not typical," and she's like,
"You always say that."
But it isn't, I don't do things six nights
in a row.
It's not typical.
That's not the kind of life I have, man.
Right, by the way I have
something the next two nights too
'cause that's another factor.
Oh really?
Yeah I got like--
Well maybe you'll
beat my streak.
Welcome back
to school nights, two different schools.
In the end you will probably tie me.
I did something on Thursday
and then on Saturday.
You only did something on Friday.
We went to the Kacey Musgraves
concert with our wives.
That was--
Fabulous.
That's a great time.
I love that woman.
Yeah 'cause I went
to The Rolling Stones
concert the night before.
Oh you did go to The
Rolling Stones concert.
Yeah man I'm tempted to talk about that.
First of all, I frickin'
love Kacey Musgraves.
I mean, she's, the album is amazing.
She played most of it.
It was wonderful.
It's exactly what I love to listen to.
But I gotta say, seeing
The Rolling Stones,
who I would not call
myself a huge Stones fan
before going to see them,
that was absolutely amazing.
Everybody in the Rose Bowl
was just in awe of the fact
that these, how old did I say Mick was?
76?
76 years old,
four months after having a
heart valve replacement surgery,
he's struttin' around
the stage for two hours,
going an estimated 14 miles total.
So crazy, I don't know, it's just--
And they sounded good.
It's 'cause the devil's in him.
That's how he's able to do it.
He had sympathy for the devil.
Man, me and Britton had a great time.
It was his treat.
It was a long time comin' 'cause
the heart valve replacement
but man I get it.
I get the Stones now, I
feel like I'm an insider.
I got the lips and the tongue on my shirt.
Oh gosh.
Good, best band logo maybe of all time.
It is, I kinda feel like
going to The Rolling Stones
and then Kacey Musgraves--
Back to back, baby.
It's not the ideal, because you're gonna--
Yeah.
You're gonna judge
Kacey Musgraves' show-womanship
versus The Rolling Stones
which is just, she's
doing a different thing.
Oh absolutely, but anyway,
you went to a party.
I went to the one thing
that you didn't go to.
And let's call it a
fundraiser, it was a fundraiser
for a charity that we're involved with,
and there was a guy there who
I've met a couple of times.
He's a older guy and he's older than me,
and super nice guy and
we were having a bunch
of interesting conversations
about some stuff
that he was involved with,
but one of the things
that he needed to show me,
we got into a conversation
about jackfruit.
Jackfruit.
Yeah,
and I recently had seen how
big a jackfruit could be.
Have you seen how big
a jackfruit could be?
I can't even say I know what
a jackfruit actually is.
Okay so you know--
Like a grapefruit?
No, not like a grapefruit.
So you know when you go
to a vegan restaurant
and they've got barbecue
but it's not barbecue,
it's something else.
Oh yeah.
Often it's this jackfruit thing.
Kinda stringy.
Yes.
It's got an interesting texture to it.
That's jackfruit and so
yeah, looks like that.
And it's kinda spiky on the outside.
It's green, the color of an avocado,
it's shaped like, how big is it?
Okay well how big would
you think that that was
just looking at it?
It looked about
as big as an avocado or an apple.
It's this big.
What?
They can be 70, this guy said--
Twice the size of an average watermelon?
Yeah so--
What?
Yeah so when I went to--
Good gracious.
That fruit is jacked.
This guy's actually helping
to import some jackfruit
into California and jackfruit is exploding
in popularity, right?
So and I had just with
Locke at the grocery store
a week ago had seen a
jackfruit and I was like,
how in the, that's a
jackfruit, it's that big?
And we almost got it as
a gag gift for Jessie.
Like let's bring home this jackfruit
and see what she does with
it, 'cause it was just so big.
Anyway, we start talking
about the business
that he's involved in
in getting jackfruits in
and he's like, "Oh I gotta
show you this one I found."
So he takes out his
phone, he begins scrolling
through his photos and he's like, "Okay,
"hold on.
"No, I'm getting close.
"No, that's, okay," just
moving his thumb like this
and just rifling through
hundreds, thousands--
Uh-huh.
Of photos.
Okay.
Two and a half minutes into
the scrolling and just saying,
"Hold on I'm almost there,
just give me a sec,"
I begin to think that I am the victim
of a YouTube prank video.
You started looking around for cameras?
I begin to think that I
might be on What Would You Do
with Quinones which incidentally
I think is a YouTube channel now.
What Would You Do if
somebody scrolled forever?
How long would it take in their scrolling
for you to just jump in and stop 'em.
Did you think about that?
Hey man, you know what,
just email it to me.
Well at one point I was like, "Yeah yeah,
"I know they're big, man."
I was like, "Yeah I saw
one at the grocery store."
He's like, "No no, you
gotta see this one."
Two and a half minutes is a long time
to watch somebody scroll.
Are you looking over his
shoulder on his phone
and is he scrolling through
nothing but photos of jackfruit?
Lots of photos of fruits.
Oh really?
And the things that he imports.
He's like, "This is my
girlfriend and this is when
"we went to the beach," you know--
No no--
"This is my dog."
He is rifling through a grid of photos.
There was like a wound on my dog.
I had to send this picture to the vet.
No no he's not giving any
commentary on the stuff
that he's scrolling through,
he's just saying, there,
and you keep thinking, okay here,
and then it's not there
and then he keeps going.
Now you know me, I'm a nice man.
And I--
You're nicer to strangers.
I have a high tolerance
for this kind of behavior.
I don't know if it's average tolerance,
it's either average or higher tolerance.
Well you have a higher
tolerance than I do.
Oh hell yeah.
Let's at least say that.
And so then it was like,
what am I gonna do?
I had time to start having
an existential crisis.
'Cause every time I'd look
back he was just saying,
"Hold on.
"Here we go, here we go, no no."
And so, I was just like I
guess I'm just gonna stay
here in the moment.
I'm gonna let this guy
find his big ass jackfruit.
And then when I see it, I'm
gonna be really impressed.
So I did that.
Well there's kind of
a lot of build up so--
It was pretty big.
Oh so he did find it.
It is really big.
He found it?
Yeah yeah it was very large.
You're not even telling
that part of the story.
You're like oh yeah he did find it.
So what the story's over?
It was 70.
Tell me about the frickin' jackfruit.
70 pounds, the jackfruit was 70 pounds.
70 pounds.
That tall, three feet tall, I don't know.
Good gosh, what gave you a sense of scale?
Was he holding a penny in his foot?
Him.
Him holding it.
Good gosh,
they can get, jackfruits can get big.
Wow, wow wow wow.
I bet they don't taste as good.
Of course they never taste like--
It's like a big catfish,
you don't want a real big catfish.
It never tastes like pork.
You could put feet on that and a snout
and it would be like a vegan pig.
It's literally as big as a pig.
Jackfruit takes on the
flavors of whatever,
it's a lot like tofu,
takes on the flavors.
But let's get back to the scrolling
'cause I do want to talk about that.
Well you know what, he
got back to the scrolling.
Again?
After he found the jackfruit.
He's a scroller.
Another, I lost count,
three to four times,
he had something in his mind
that he wanted to show me
and he would go back
to the photos and then,
I don't think it was ever
as long as that first time
but I was like, this is
like a Seinfeld episode
if Seinfeld was made in 2019.
He's the scroller.
Now you know what, somebody
needs to talk to him
'cause he's too dependent on photos.
He needs to just do hand gestures.
You know how like--
It was this big.
Or pick up a small child and
be like, "It was this big."
Or make it his wallpaper.
If the anecdote comes up that often,
you need to have it
printed on a business card.
I think this is the perfect example
of why you need favorites.
You need to take advantage
of your favorites feature
on your photo collection.
Yeah you're talking about makin' an album.
If you need, oh, here's the photo of me
with my kids, here's the
photo of the big-ass jackfruit
that I love to talk about.
The stories I always tell
but then spend way too much time scrolling
for the payoff photo album.
That's what you call it.
Yes.
I've actually thought a lot about this.
Okay good.
Pausing a story to scroll,
because actually on the way
to The Rolling Stones concert,
we were in an Uber,
Britton and I were both
in the backseat and this guy was like,
this guy was coming on strong.
He wanted to know
everything about us and--
Really?
Inquisitive Uber drivers,
those are the worst.
He had something hanging from his mirror
that said Phish, the band.
Uh-oh.
So then Britton starts talking about Phish
so then literally for 20 minutes,
the two of them are
just talking about Phish
and I'm like this is great.
I don't wanna be a part of this.
I'm just over here looking out the window,
looking at my phone.
But the guy, he made such
a connection with Britton,
he was like oh he's an artist.
He was like I used to be a producer
but I only charged $15 an hour and--
That didn't last long.
He had this hard luck
story and then he's like,
"Give me your information
to put in my phone.
"Let me give you my information
to put in your phone,"
so he made Britton put his
name and number in his phone
and then he's like, and
then he pulls up a notepad
and he's writing down Britton's
information, I'm like,
he's not coming for me.
He's like, "What about you?
"What's your name?"
It's like 30 minutes in the conversation.
Charles, that's when you say Charles.
I think I said, I think I
said Link because maybe,
I was thinking about that.
You have the best excuse in the world.
I say James quite a bit.
At Starbucks my frickin' name is James.
He was like, "And what
do you do for a living?"
And I was like, I froze.
And then I was like,
"I'm a video producer."
I did not, this is the last
guy on earth I wanted to get--
Video producer.
He was like what kind
of videos, I was like--
Digital.
I was like, I was like,
"Corporate videos."
No, what, you lied, man.
I said I make corporate, well--
We are a corporation.
I make videos
on a corporate platform.
Google is a corporation.
We're a corporation, yeah.
And we're a corporation so--
Yeah you didn't lie.
On a couple of levels
I make corporate videos
and I said, "I like to think
that if people don't watch
"my videos they would die."
What was Britton doing when
you said corporate videos?
Corporate videos are
typically like safety videos.
I never made eye contact with Britton.
I was pretty ashamed of what I was doing.
I'm a video producer of corporate videos.
My name is Charles, please stop talking.
What was my point, oh
yeah, and then he goes back
to talking about the Phish concert--
Hey, mission accomplished, man.
Mission accomplished and
he's like, he's like,
"Man I was on the front row of this show,"
and he starts scrolling through his--
He's scrolling and driving?
He's scrolling and driving,
well we're in bumper
to bumper traffic in the Rose Bowl.
Got it, all right.
We're trapped with this guy.
It could be an hour.
Trapped with a scroller.
And now he's scrolling and
his phone's up there mounted.
I mean I'm like, should I look away?
Should I look at his photos?
He's not scrolling that
quickly and he's saying things.
He was like, "Oh this is me
and my girl at the beach,
"and this is like a screen
shot I took of something,"
it's like--
Oh well at least
he's a commentary-laden
scroller which is better
than a non-commentary scroller.
But I feel like you should look away.
It's kinda like when somebody's
entering their password,
like if you wanna help
somebody with their laptop
like an in-law or something,
you wanna avert your eyes
when they put their password
in, you know what I'm saying?
I do, I don't see how it's relevant
but I appreciate.
Well when somebody's
scrolling through their
entire photo life--
You're seeing into their life.
Just to get to a jackfruit,
you never know what you
might see and I don't,
there's lots of things I don't
wanna see an Uber driver do,
you know what I'm saying?
Okay got it, yeah.
You know?
That's a different album.
I'd like to see him
just drive and be quiet.
He actually talked about,
he made a comment about,
"Man, I really enjoy
talking to you," and this is
in the middle of the
conversation, not the end.
Talking to Britton, he was
like, "'Cause a lot of people
"get in the car and they're like,
"they're like, they'll just be quiet.
"I'm like I'm a human, you're a human."
And I'm thinking, that's me, man.
I don't really think you can call that a.
I know, he was kind of harsh.
I mean some people just don't
wanna have a conversation.
And then he's like, "I'm
coming to this show later."
And then he's like, "I'm gonna
pull you guys right up here,"
and he's like, he goes through the parking
and they were charging
20 bucks for parking.
He was like, "I'm just
dropping these guys off,"
so they let him go through
and then he's like,
"I'm not leaving," and then it dawns on me
as he's pulling into a parking space,
this guy's gonna be with us all night.
And then he's like, he's
parking the car, he's like,
"I'm gonna give you five stars
and I'm coming to the show,"
it's like, "Do you guys
have an extra ticket?"
And I was like, "No,"
thank goodness we don't
have an extra ticket.
I'm coming to the show,
do you have an extra,
you're not coming to the show
unless you can get a ticket.
Right so then we split up
but for a second I thought
he was gonna be with us all night
because he already had a ticket.
I think you would have shut that down.
I would have, absolutely.
I think even I would have shut that down.
But I wouldn't have
stared at his scrolling.
See I'm still, I'm human.
And I think people who have a low capacity
or a high capacity for
tolerating scrolling
have a low capacity for
exposing people to scrolling.
Sure.
I've got like,
I'll scroll for 12 seconds,
then I feel like I'm
inconveniencing somebody
and then I'm like, you know
what, don't worry about it.
I think I'll Google photos.
You can type in jackfruit and
it would literally pull up--
You can do that on the iPhone as well.
And I almost told him that
but I just didn't--
Of course it will pull up
3000 images--
I kept thinking
he was gonna find it.
For him.
Right.
So--
All right so we can talk
about that forever but
we're gonna talk about--
Let's go down another--
Robots.
Wild rabbit trail.
But first, you can get
this shirt that I'm wearing
which is part of the
Post-Apawcalypse Collection
at Mythical.com.
This is one of three
different shirts you can get.
There's also, I don't
know what's still there.
We got hats, we got a bandana,
we got sweatpants.
The sweatpants
were a big hit.
Yeah and I think those are still up there.
Get 'em while they're still there.
Lots of stuff constantly
updated at Mythical.com.
Rep ya boys, check it out,
support internetainment
and feel good, like it literally
feels good to wear stuff.
It feels good and it's just a cool shirt.
You're not like hey.
If you're the kinda person who's like,
hey I'm a fan of this show
and you don't wanna be
that person where you're like,
hey, I got a cool shirt on.
This is for the cool shirt folks.
Okay let's get into this.
I have this habit of laying in bed
and I just pull up the Reddit thread
because it just sends me into a world
that's not my own.
There's many things, many
threads that I follow
that are relaxing,
educational, entertaining,
mesmerizing, but in no
way related to my work,
whereas if I pull up Twitter
then that's a problem
because I feel like even
if I just look at tweets
of comedians, I start to get anxiety.
Interesting.
Ang-xiety,
with a G.
'Cause I just feel like,
it's the social media trap
of comparison, I think
I do it on that level,
on some sort of professional level.
I don't tweet, I'm not funny, oh.
And then even on Instagram,
I know we did a whole episode
about it but that's starting to creep in,
so a little bit of that.
But it's mostly just like exotic locations
that I look at on Instagram
and that's not deep enough.
I need something deeper
and Reddit gives me my fix.
So let me take you on a journey.
I think, yeah, this was, no
this wasn't the popular page.
It was posted in a couple
of different threads.
But the one that I follow is
educational GIFs or GIFs if you will.
And the title of the post is,
this is how canning process is done.
Exclamation point.
And then it's a re-post
or an imbed post of,
from the Reddit thread manufacturing porn
called Codi canning
process, exclamation point.
You know when you hear canning process,
it might sound boring but if
you add an exclamation point
at the end, I'm listening.
This is how it's made.
So yeah, it's a video of
a can of what appears,
what is beer.
I couldn't tell what it
was 'cause it's like,
it's not a can that I would recognize.
Maybe Codi is a name brand,
I actually don't know.
So this video's cool because
yes, of course it loops,
but it shows three different steps
in the manufacturing
process before it loops,
so it starts and you see 'em spinning
on the lid of a can.
And I had never really
understood, I was really drawn in,
I never really understood
that the top of a can,
like where you pop it
open, that sealed on.
I never thought about it.
Right.
And then the camera moves,
after it shows you a number
of these lids being slapped on the cans,
then it moves earlier in the process
and shows you, right before
the, no, that's later
in the process, it twists the can lid
and spins off all the beer
foam and then it goes earlier
in the process and shows
you all this foamy beer
coming out before the lid is slapped on.
I think this GIF is just
looping in the wrong place
or maybe, 'cause this is
the beginning coming in,
coming in with the beer.
See the beer coming in
with all the foam, then
they scrape the foam off
and then they throw a lid on
and the way that the
lid slides on is just--
I never thought about the fact that--
Nice.
You know 'cause
it's contents under pressure,
does that mean that it's extra
carbonated when it goes in?
Is that why, I would
think with that much foam
at the top there would be more
foam underneath the surface
and so when you end up
getting a can of beer,
it would have like an inch missing of beer
'cause the foam would have
just turned into liquid.
But it's completely full.
I just don't understand how
this process leads to that.
'Cause it's like overflowing right there.
Yeah they fill it up to
where the foam is all the way
at the top and then
they smash the lid down
so there is some pressure
and it's probably from
the carbonation of the beer
or whatever you would call it.
See this is where you're going
and if you were a commenter,
this is what you might comment.
And if you knew that, so
you might ask that question,
if someone would come in
and answer the question,
and then the rest of us would learn that.
So whenever I watch a video
like this, first of all,
I'm mesmerized by it and then I'm just,
I'm like there's 343
comments under this video.
Mm-hmm.
I wonder where it goes and
I wonder what most people
have engaged in which will rise to the top
if you don't use Reddit.
I'm just giving you a little background.
So it could be anything,
they could be talking
about anything and the first comment,
the beginning of my journey, says F word.
I'm not gonna say it.
Let's just not.
Those machines must suck to maintain.
So we got a Debbie Downer right
at the top of this thread.
People talk about how unclean
it is because basically,
there's beer foam going all over the can
and then in the next
step, they spin the can
at a rapid, aggressive speed
and then this beer foam goes everywhere.
So this is what someone commented
and then everybody seemed
to engage under this one comment.
Yeah so the person says
those machines must suck
to maintain, of course, I'm like yeah,
I was kinda thinking that
myself now that you mention it.
And then the person says,
someone else responds,
sticky, smelly mess.
Don't forget that.
But clearly,
that is not really the case.
Beer is a perishable product.
Those machines are cleaned religiously
because otherwise beer
won't have a long shelf life
due to contamination.
It can be sticky during
the shift but overall,
it's kept clean.
I worked for a hotdog manufacturer
and every single machine
was deconstructed,
soaped up, scrubbed and
rinsed, then reassembled
at the end of every shift.
At this point I'm like
dang, I'm taking a journey
to the end of a hotdog shift.
And they're frickin' disassembling
the entire machinery,
washing it all down.
I know you're going other places
but I have to say that
why can't they just steam the whole thing?
Why can't there just be a steam component
that comes in and just
blasts it with steam
and soap and stuff, why
can't it be self-cleaning?
I don't understand why you can't,
why you gotta take it apart?
Surely this is--
Crevices.
This isn't how everything is done.
Crevices, man.
Hotdog and beer gets in crevices.
Hotdog probably gets into
more crevices than beer.
And you can't get it out.
So now I'm on this cleaning
manufacturing lines thread
and I'm all in.
I was actually surprised
at myself at this point
that I was so interested in
this and I will keep reading.
Okay.
I have an industrial engineering degree.
It's basically a degree
that teaches you not how
to make things, not how...
Not to design things but to
design how the things are made.
Mm-hmm.
So it's the designing
and manufacturing process.
Right.
Once the thing that you
know you wanna create
has already been designed.
Well what's the most efficient or clean
or safe or all of the above way
to actually get that thing made?
Get that beer canned.
One of my favorite classes was,
there was a manufacturing processes class
and we would just go and
take tours of factories.
Well yeah tours, I guess
it's a field trip class.
Yeah field trip class.
Yeah.
So you got the hotdog
manufacturer talking about
deconstructing, soaping
up, scrubbing, rinsing,
re-assembling the machines
at the end of every shift
and then someone commented,
and people say automation
will take jobs away.
And then, funky credo comes
in and says, it already did.
The company I worked for was in Ukraine.
Due to cheap labor costs, the
level of automation is low
since it's not cost effective.
Our facility made four
tons an hour of hotdogs
using multiple manufacturing
lines and close
to 100 people per shift
directly on those lines.
I toured a number of
facilities in the U.S.,
most are so automated that a
single line makes eight tons
an hour which is twice as much with only
eight people directly
involved as opposed to 100.
And then someone commented
I bet those eight people
got a ton of, to clean and it
probably doesn't all get done.
No.
I used to work in a pastry
facility doing sanitation.
Yes, now we're, we're going
from beer to hotdog to pastry.
People working in factories--
Riveting.
Coming out of the woodwork
and I am here for it!
I noticed that.
Pretty much everything can be power washed
in most facilities, making
it incredibly easy to clean.
See this is the question you had.
Why do they have to take stuff apart?
Really, do you really need to do that?
Plus, we had to pass cleanliness
inspections every morning
which involved multiple cotton swap tests
on every machine for food bacteria.
We cleaned the entire facility--
Facili-lilidly.
Facility.
This is a
industrial engineer here.
We cleaned the entire
facility with three people
versus the 15 that worked the line.
Needless to say, I'd
far trust U.S. cleaning
since it is typically all
designed to be cleaned
and multiple tests are run
before the facility can even open.
Yeah 'cause the moment
that you get bacteria
on the equipment and it's
transferred to the food,
you basically are completely shut down.
Your livelihood is gone so--
Right.
All the incentives are to
maintain very high standards.
And another commenter
comes in and talks about
how in other facilities that the machines
do start to clean themselves.
But there's still rigorous
swabbing that's happening.
Right.
I think I would do good
in a place that involved
rigorous swabbing but I
would still be very anxious.
You'd probably never find
anything on your swab.
But even the rigorous
swabbing can easily be,
well not easily, will
eventually be automated.
I mean, all steps can be automated.
The rigorous swabbing, rigorous
swabbing will be automated.
Right, it could be automated.
Right.
And robots probably gonna be better
at evaluating the swab
to some dude named Bill.
And then trephination by 45 swoops in
and expands the convo.
Uh-oh.
There's an interesting albeit
slightly esoteric argument
for automation that suggests
that once we as a species
get through the initial bumps
of steadily implementing it
more and more that
humans will thus be able
to concentrate their
lives more on their truly
passionate pursuits due
to the vast elimination
of boring, tedious tasks.
That once we're free of
manually having to quote,
waste our lives, performing
the various tasks
out of necessity, we'd
have the opportunity
to become more in touch with our humanity
and spend our time pursuing
the things that we truly love
and that a majority of
previous jobs that related
to performing such boring
work would translate
towards less intensive
automation supervision
or orchestration, et cetera.
Obviously there's much much
more nuance to that sort
of cultural development
but it does strike me
as an interesting and somewhat
counter-intuitive notion,
don't you think?
I think that there's a lot of assumptions
about human behavior built into that.
Yeah yeah.
Haven't you seen WALL-E?
There is an assumption that
we, once we're freed up,
people will instinctively
concentrate their lives more
on their truly passionate pursuits.
Some people will.
Yeah in WALL-E, as I call it,
if memory serves me, I don't
remember much of the plot.
Well if memory serves you correct.
Much of the dialogue.
It could serve you incorrectly.
It could mis, it could disserve.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of unhealthy
people just slobbin' around--
Watching television.
In hover recliners
watching screens.
Right.
Robots doing everything.
Which I mean--
On spaceships--
We have--
Leaving the planet because
it has been destroyed.
We do have some data on this, right?
There are people who don't
work for whatever reason,
I'm not talking about people
who want to work and can't
but people who are choosing not to work,
they might be retired.
I guess the retired
community is an example.
So you've got people who are
inactive and watch television,
eat and watch television and
become the types of people
that are featured in WALL-E
and then you have another set
of the population that
chooses to do activities,
what might be referred
to as active leisure.
Mm-hmm.
Some things are more
active than others.
So you're using the retirement thing
as an analogous to, well,
if your job was taken away
and then you had to find a new job,
but you would have to find one,
you would have the opportunity to find one
that you were more engaged in.
Well--
Than something that was
more monotonous that a robot could do it.
And I like to extrapolate things out to
just the logical conclusion, right,
a lot of people make
all kinds of arguments
about how automation is
actually not going to lead
to unemployment and I
don't really wanna get
into it, that's kind
of a, I don't wanna get
into that boring conversation.
I think that--
We could just talk about
cleaning manufacturing
equipment the whole time
if you don't wanna make
sure we're not boring.
Well what I'm saying
is I don't wanna debate
whether or not automation
is gonna really be a problem
for people's jobs, but I think
that it's kind of unavoidable
if we don't, which I actually
think that the chance is
that we exterminate ourselves
because we're not dealing
with global crises in
a way that we should.
We're dividing as opposed
to unifying, coming together
and solving problems.
I think we'll probably--
Preach.
I think we will exterminate
ourselves before
we actually get to this
point but let's just say
people wake up and realize
that the world is falling apart
and dying and we actually
need to do something about it.
Let's assume that humans--
Well by the way,
that is WALL-E, they left Earth.
Right.
They had to abandon it.
Yeah well let's assume that
we wake up and figure it out.
Then it is inevitable that
technology will progress
to a place where we have
the option to get the robots
to do all the stuff that
we don't want to do.
Let's ignore robot's
rights issues and whether
or not they'll have personhood.
That'll become a debate, it
already is, whatever, okay.
We'll let them worry about that.
Yeah but it is inevitable that we'll get
to a point where you don't
have to be the person
to clean the beer machines
or the hotdog machines.
Like you could if you want to maybe,
but actually you probably
won't even be allowed to
because you'll be way worse at it.
And so and even the jobs
that we have, like okay,
it isn't that far off that, first of all,
there's already AI that's
making YouTube videos
and there'll be the first
completely AI generated movie
in however many years and people will go,
eventually, the stuff
created by the robots
and this may take several
generations, many generations,
but eventually the robots will be able
to create better than us.
And you will enjoy a
movie created by robots
from top to bottom more
than the one made by humans.
Right?
Everything will be eventually replaced.
The robots will be able to
do it better eventually.
I just--
Then what are we gonna do?
I can't believe that a
purely creative endeavor,
when subject to so much,
so much sensibility--
No I'm saying--
Could ever be--
This is way, way, way,
way, way far in the future
because replicating the human
mind and human intuition.
I mean did you see the thing where,
this could be, I don't
know if this is just one
of those internet things that's not true
but you know the picture of the chihuahuas
and the blueberry muffins in the grid?
Oh yeah.
And somebody sent that
to, I think a text thread
that we're on and they were like--
I think Jessie sent it.
AI is not able to tell the difference
between the blueberry
muffins and the chihuahuas.
Now if I squinted, I couldn't either.
Right but as a human you can look at it
and within about half a
second you can determine
which one's a chihuahua and
which one's a blueberry muffin.
Apparently AI still can't do that, right.
But they will be able to do
that if they can't already
if that's just a meme that isn't true.
What I don't understand is why robots
can't push the button that says
I am not a robot on websites.
Now that seems pretty simple.
You should be there, robot.
Really good point.
That's an opportunity.
It literally says
I am not a robot and then just
one button that just check,
it's like a check box.
So I'm pretty much,
I'm eroding your entire
argument with that.
They can't check the box, man.
But they will.
I'm just saying that
there's gonna be all kinds
of ups and downs, all kinds of arguments,
ethical conundrums leading to a place,
but eventually technology inevitably,
if you don't exterminate
yourself, it progresses to a place
where something you create
surpasses anything that you are.
I just think that that's inevitable.
So there will be--
And cool.
There will be a point
in which you're like,
I don't have to contribute,
essentially, to society.
I mean the thread goes on
to universal basic income.
Which, you know, I don't
really have the appetite
to go there except to say that,
well, some people will
say well if that exists,
then I actually don't know but I presume
that there's then an argument on one side
that's like, well you know,
then it gives people a padding
that then they're not gonna do anything.
You've got the low level,
you've got the base level income
that you need to thrive,
so it really comes back to,
and we can make this about us but,
what do you do if you have free time?
I mean if you have to find a job
and there's no financial cushion there,
then hopefully we're creating enough jobs
where everybody can get one.
It just doesn't make
sense to me that everybody
will automatically be able to then move
to what they're most passionate about
but I also don't know that most people,
if they are financially secure enough,
I think there's some
people who then go wild
with their passions
and there's some people who just go lazy.
Yeah, it's very personality dependent.
Yeah and I actually feel, I
feel like my natural instinct
is toward the entropy of just
laziness, just falling apart.
I don't think, no, I don't think so.
I think you get very
frustrated with yourself
if you actually did that with your time.
But I'm reading a book right now--
I would become depressed.
Yeah.
But I think I would have
to push through that.
I think I'd have to go through--
I think you would.
I think I would have
to go through that valley.
I'm reading a book right
now that I'm not gonna say
what it is because it might
be a rec once I get through
and decide that it's a rec and by rec,
a Rec in Effect at the end of the show.
Just say what--
No.
You can give it again.
No, no.
You don't know if it's good?
Yeah 'cause I feel like it might be
a strong recommendation
but I'm only like a third
through it but one of the
principles that is being discussed
in the book is essentially where people,
you have this idea that okay,
well what I'm going to do
when I get old and I've done my work
and it's time to retire is I'm going to be
as my Instagram, shout-out
to @rhettmc on Instagram.
As my Instagram bio says,
future international man of leisure.
Right, and it's a joke
that I just came up with.
It's kind of a non-joke.
It's a playful description.
I think, it will turn
some people against you.
Yeah and as a result of this conversation,
and as a result of this book I'm reading,
I actually think I'm going to change that.
Yeah, I definitely hate you because of it.
Now but so--
Why?
The implication is that,
okay, when I have free time,
I'm going to be a man of, and
I would say active leisure,
travel, experiencing things or whatever.
Kitesurfer.
I don't think I'm gonna go there.
Now--
Shoulders.
The argument that this
guy makes in the book
is that people who live lives
of purpose and have true joy
are those who, actually,
as they get older,
they actually increase their
commitments to other people.
It might be a commitment to a cause
or a commitment to a
community or an organization
or an individual, but essentially,
that people who are the most satisfied
and the most purpose-oriented
are the people
who have commitments.
I gotta be there for
something or for somebody.
Six nights in a row.
And that's not what my six
nights in a row had been about
but you know what I'm saying.
Yeah.
And that kinda struck me,
I was like first of all,
this isn't fundamentally,
goes against anything
that I already believe or
think or want for my life,
but it made me think differently
about that little quip
in my Instagram bio because
I do like to think about,
hey we're gonna travel
and we're gonna do this
and he's like everyone thinks
that that's what they want
to do but that life gets
pretty empty pretty quickly
and so I think that the real question,
the ethical question when
people have this free time,
'cause we're just, we're talking in the,
we're assuming that people
are gonna have the option
to be like, okay, I get
my universal basic income
and now I can play video
games, I can get lost in VR
which that's gonna be
a huge cultural problem
as people getting just basically
living their lives online.
And then other people will just
binge-watch them VRing their lives.
Right, but the...
I think the people who
are gonna be truly happy,
like you're talking about
fighting through this depression,
right, okay, if you
commit yourself to just
personal pursuits, I'm gonna
go do what I want to do
whether that's watch TV or go kitesurfing,
it could be active.
I do think that eventually
you're gonna be like,
I kinda just, there's not a lot here.
This isn't what--
Why am I here?
Humans are not--
Why am I even still here?
Yeah and so the principle in
this book is that we think
we're all about independence
but really we're built
for interdependence and so I
think that there's this idea
that listen, we evolved in community
and you go back just a very,
very short period of time
to where we were living
in these communities
of 100 to 150 individuals
that all had a role
and you were contributing
to each other's lives,
you were involved in each
other's lives emotionally,
physically, and you were
helping raise children
and that kinda thing--
And when you got old,
you were valued for your perspective.
Yeah.
Your wisdom.
And so I think that again,
if we don't exterminate ourselves,
we get to this point
where the robots are doing
all the work, the only way we will survive
as a species is if we somehow
replicate this community
that exists for our own health.
You know what I'm saying,
we will come up with roles--
Absolutely.
And interactions
and relationships for our
own personal well-being
that may not even be,
they're not contributing
to the GDP, 'cause the
robots are doing all that.
This just becomes about just
well-being amongst people.
First of all, ton of people.
That's something to pay for.
Billions of people.
You can make a living doing that.
More people than the world
can probably support but--
It doesn't have to be charity,
there's occupations associated with this
and more can be invented.
This is exactly what I was
getting at when I was like
aspirationally I want
to be the type of person
that takes life by the horns.
We don't, my Nanny Lucille, my mom's mom,
she worked her entire
life in a shirt factory.
Right.
And my Aunt Vicky right beside her.
Aunt Vicky was a folder I believe
and Nanny was an inspector.
The little sticker you get with a number--
With name on that.
Well the number was--
Inspected by Lucille.
Lucille was number,
I don't know maybe she was number nine.
She's number one to me.
But that's accountability in the factory.
That's why they put the sticker there.
It's not for anybody else,
just if something screwed up,
then Nanny gets a demerit.
But I mean, it's that red
cap factory on the far side
of Lillington across from Bird's Drive-In,
that trailer where they
had the amazing burgers.
Yeah.
And now it's, there's just
a Burger King over there
and it sucks.
Every day of her life, I
mean, I'll need to ask her
how many years but like--
She did it longer than Vicky right,
or maybe they stopped--
Well she retired.
'Cause Vicky went to work at the school.
Well yeah.
But her entire working life
she worked in one shirt factory
the entire time, man.
Right.
I mean it's like, we have this amazing job
where we're so creatively fulfilled
and every day's different.
Our calendar's filled up and
we're told where we have to be
and what we have to do and we
have to fill all these slots
and we get grumpy but we have,
we are doing our passions, like--
Oh yeah.
There's few people on the
planet that the percentage
of their time is dedicated
as highly as ours is
to our passions.
Yeah.
And maybe that's a factor but for me,
but I think it's more
still a personality type
that there's probably both that okay,
if I had time I would just like veg out.
And maybe that's because I'm so fulfilled
and maybe the average person
who isn't would more likely
pursue that than not but I
wanna be the type of person
that as I continue to
gain space in my life
to make decisions with what I wanna do
that it's things that are healthy
but also meaningful and beyond myself.
You can save the rec but just
tell me the name of the book.
I feel like I'd like the
maybe read this book.
It's called "The Second Mountain".
"The Second Mountain", okay.
Yeah so I'm interested in
that, 'cause I don't know
that I'm that type of person.
Even this weekend, I'm
going camping with the kids
but it's because our
friend Nick said, "Hey,
"I'm going camping with my kids.
"Do you wanna come?"
And I was like, they're
probably not gonna wanna come
and then I asked the kids
and they wanted to go
and I'm like yes, 'cause
I didn't wanna take them,
I didn't wanna force.
Yeah.
I was so happy.
There was a tinge of self-judgment
that I wouldn't have gone
camping unless I was invited.
I had the time and my
family has the appetite,
but it would have, but I
didn't take the initiative
to do it and I wanna be the
type of person that's like,
continues to not just sit on my butt.
I don't--
Maybe I'm too hard on myself.
I think you're being too hard on yourself
because I think that--
Climb that second mountain.
Literally.
Like when your wife texted
me and my wife a picture of
you lounging next to your pool
this past Saturday and she said,
this is post nude swim Link,
and you just had a towel.
You were asleep and you
had a towel draped over
your nether regions and she
was like still nude by the way.
I didn't judge you, man.
You know what I thought to myself,
man I should take a nude swim right now.
I should be in my pool naked
and then lounging next to it.
That's what I thought.
Sometimes a man needs to swim naked, man.
Yeah and you can zoom in on me, look.
Look at how--
You look so contented.
Look how content I am here.
Don't worry Kiko, I'm
taking a screenshot for ya
so you can see my contented
naked body lounging by my pool
and share it with the people.
'Cause I'm passionate about it!
Again 'cause I think that--
I don't feel bad about that.
I think that so much
of what makes us happy
is trying to find a way to
interact with the modern world
in a way that is sort of in symphony
with our actual biology.
You know what I'm saying
and that's just a,
I talk about this and you're tired of it
and you don't wanna hear
me talk about it again
when I say it all the time
about Stone Age hardware
and modern age software
and those are kinda,
the source of so many of our problems.
But I just feel that way and so like,
what you're doing when
you lay next to your pool
after you've had, we work hard.
Yeah we have a great job.
It's not a hard labor
job, my hands are soft.
You know what I'm saying.
The tips of my fingers, the
tips of my left hand fingers
are pretty callous
because I play the guitar
but my hands are soft.
I used to shake hands with my Uncle Jake
who was a pipe welder and that dude,
it was just like going
into the sandpaper section
of the Home Depot and just
brushing up against it.
His hands, it was something
other than human skin.
It was like boulders wrapped in sandpaper.
Yeah.
Wrapped around your hands.
It was just like touching
a man wearing a glove
and then you're oh he
doesn't have a glove on.
His hand has become a glove.
And that man worked hard, lived hard,
died young.
We don't live that kind of life.
Well he shouldn't have stared
right into the welding part.
I don't think that's what it was.
He took the appropriate
safety measures I believe.
Well he didn't wear gloves.
We have a pretty, we get
to do, like you said,
privilege out the wazoo,
we get to do what we want.
We make our own schedules but
we have committed ourselves
thoroughly to these
aspirations and these dreams
on this probably delusional level
and we end up spending a lot of time on it
so when I get home at
night or on the weekends,
I am exhausted because emotional
exertion is a real thing.
We're putting our hearts,
souls into what we're doing
and performing and creating
and it is exhausting
and it does have a physical toll.
So I don't, you shouldn't
feel bad about that.
I think what we're really
talking about--
Okay I don't anymore.
I think what we're really
talking about is when,
when we don't have those obligations.
'Cause I kinda feel like
I know what I would do
if all of a sudden, everything was good.
Everything was taken care of,
all the people that I
love are taken care of
and you know, I could just
step away from everything
that we built and just like,
I can do anything that I want.
What I would most likely do,
my first inclination is to just
fill my time with other creative endeavors
but things that don't necessarily have
to be a commercial success, right?
And maybe things that
wouldn't even be enjoyed
by lots of people, it
might just be like oh,
I'm gonna create in this
particular way, write,
or paint or whatever or I've
got this passion project
and I wanna do it.
And I think that even that
would become kinda unfulfilling
at some point, right?
Because unless I was able
to direct those passions
and what I can do
creatively into greater good
to support something or support someone,
I think eventually those things
wouldn't be very fulfilling.
Right now I think the
thing that keeps us going
and keeps us so busy is again,
and I do think it's slightly delusional
and that's probably a good
thing is we just have this idea
that oh the next thing
that we're gonna create is
the best thing we've ever created
and we're gonna find
some way to get somebody
to help us make it.
And we have this sort of
rolling list of things
that we feel like we have to do.
But eventually we're
gonna get to the end of,
one of two things is gonna happen.
We're gonna do the things on that list
and then realize that they're
really not any different
from a personal satisfaction point
than anything we've ever created
and there's no real joy
and happiness there.
B, probably ore likely,
we're gonna get older before,
we're gonna lose the ability to do that
before we're able to do it.
I mean that might be a
pessimistic viewpoint,
but it's just like, my greatest
fear is that our best work
is behind us but I'm also sort
of like using historical data
to come to that conclusion that
typically, you're moving into your 40s.
It's not like you're,
I hope, I still believe
that our best work is
ahead of us, but anyway,
at some point we're gonna
get to a place where
we have either done it
or weren't able to do it
and now we gotta make a decision
about what is life gonna be?
That's the more pressing
question for me personally
because I feel like we're
gonna answering that question
for ourselves in a way
that maybe the society
as a whole is gonna be
answering that question
in the distant future because
we've got privilege to do it.
I feel like you need to
ask yourself that question
much less but the
average person might need
to ask themselves the question much more.
Like how do I engage my passion for the,
and then dot dot dot,
eventually for the greater good.
Let me continue with a thread here.
'Cause with every tangent,
there is a re-centering.
So after that, let's see,
oh this one guy shared this anecdote
which I'll quickly share.
I worked as a controls
engineer at a factory
that made sports drinks for a few years.
Beer, wieners, pastries, sports drinks.
This is my passion.
I'm gonna go back to
industrial engineering.
I think that's what I'm learning.
The factory was originally
built in the '70s
and had been constantly upgraded.
It was eerie because you'd be in a million
square foot factory plus
warehouse that ran 24/7,
producing over two million
cases of drinks per month
and there'd be 20 to 40
people on duty per shift.
So you could be on the factory floor
and potentially not see
another human being for hours.
That's crazy.
I would love to go into
a facility like that.
The break room and
parking lot were all sized
for hundreds of people
so everyone would be
on lunch break and it'd
only be a small corner
of the room with people in it.
It always felt a little bit eerie.
So when they built this
plant, there was more people
in the process.
Yeah but back in the '70s.
Yeah.
Million square foot facility.
So now there's like 20 to 40 people.
Anyway automation had
eliminated hundreds of jobs
over the decades and continue
to eliminate the remaining ones including
maintenance technicians
and housekeeping staff
as machines got more reliable
or came with more capabilities.
But and at this point I
started to think, man,
this would be cool in a movie.
This is a cool setting for a movie.
It's not even in the future, this is now.
So we don't have to make
a scifi film to do this
but I'm just planting a seed
here that like huge factory
with 20 people working in it.
Hmm.
Let's find a factory
and let's write a whole
movie in a cavernous factory
where you only see people once a day
and then you go to the break
room and they're all huddled
in the corner eating,
starved for connection.
That's eerie, man.
That's cool.
I like it.
Yeah, so that's a movie idea that I got.
And then we come to it.
There's more stuff under
people talking about
that guy's post but then I keep scrolling,
I'm about to fall asleep at this point.
Boy I've been in the canning process,
I've been power washing equipment.
I've been thinking about my
future and engaging my passions
and the future of society.
I've been thinking about a movie idea
and right before I shut my little phone
and shut my little eyes,
I read it.
Somebody comments, that was
my nickname in middle school.
And if you scroll all the
way back up to the top,
you'll remember that the
second comment was sticky,
smelly mess.
Ah.
Which someone said that was
my nickname in middle school.
Middle school, okay, that's interesting.
First comment underneath that.
Rhett, question mark.
And then other people
are commenting about it.
Of course you say, that was
my nickname in high school--
High school.
On GMM a lot,
and I was bolted, I
almost sat up on my bed.
All of a sudden I was
like totally awake again.
Yeah.
I was like, I'm--
I know him!
I'm deep, I know him!
Yeah, I'm deep in this Reddit
thread that has nothing
to do with me, you or us,
and all of a sudden, there you are.
Someone who knew you and
that dumb catchphrase.
Mm.
Felt the need to associated themselves--
I think it's a pretty good,
it's kinda like what she said.
That's what she said,
it kinda always works.
It's exactly like that
except for the fact that
if you said that's what
she said on our show a lot
and people thought that
you came up with it.
That's the thing I find funny is that
you didn't come up with--
I don't think I came up with it.
That was my nickname in high school
and you have not claimed to
do that but there are people
in the world and there are people
on this Reddit thread
apparently who so associate it
with you that I think they may believe
that you came up with the catchphrase.
I think I convinced myself
that I came up with it.
Memory, you can control that kinda thing.
Well this person got it
wrong, you say high school.
But middle school, sticky and smelly mess.
I don't know it is a little bit more
of a middle school thing.
Look it, right there,
question mark, Rhett.
Rhett?
But that didn't get much traction.
Didn't get any traction.
No no.
It got two up-votes.
Okay.
I appreciate that.
It's time to give a Rec in Effect
as we wrap down this episode.
Check baby check.
I guess it's my turn to give a rec.
Yeah.
You know what,
I didn't come very prepared today.
I would like to highly recommend a book
called "Second Mountain".
Come on, man.
I haven't started reading it
yet but Rhett was telling me
about it and you--
I'm only a third into it.
I don't like--
Rhett's only a third into it
but from what he tells me--
I don't like to recommend
things that I haven't finished.
You're not recommending it.
I'm recommending it.
Ha!
But you can't steal
my recommendation, man.
Well I'm stealing it.
I'm stealing it.
"Second Mountain" by--
I'm not gonna tell it, I'm
not gonna say who it's by.
Rupert Monday.
I don't know, come on
man, I gotta give the--
Is this really your rec?
Yes.
You don't have another rec?
David Brooks, man.
David Brooks.
"Second Mountain".
I think it's called "The Second Mountain".
I also recommend "Second Act",
a 2018 American romantic comedy
film directed by Peter Segal
and written by Elaine Goldsmith-Thomas.
'Cause that came up when
you did a Google search
for second.
Yes, #EarBiscuits, let
us know what you think
about automation, the future of society,
following your passions and somehow,
I don't normally do this but
I just wanna encourage you.
Take a moment, even if
it's just a moment today
to engage in a personal passion.
Don't wait.
And definitely stop
before you become a sticky
and sweaty mess.
Was it sticky and smelly mess?
Oi.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.